nous voilà réunis aujourd'hui pour
parler d'un produit ciel dont je voulais
vous parle déjà depuis un petit moment
et puis le temps passant je n'ai pas
encore fait et je suis pas content parce
que je voulais le faire c'est celui là
c'est le samsung galaxy à 80 on l'a
découvert un mois d'avril si je dis pas
de bêtises vous avez emmené avec moi à
paris dans un événement pour les couvrir
soit 80 je vous emmènerai t'as rien vous
allez voir c'est vachement intéressant
il ya plein de nouveaux produits et ça
c'est plutôt cool
[Musique]
le temps est venu de vous dire comment
je trouve jeu plein de points vraiment
intéressant des trucs bientôt qu'un peu
moins bien
avant toute chose je vous faire un petit
poids parce qu'il ya plein de tests
plein d'autres choses qui vont arriver
donc je vous invite dès maintenant vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas on a
celui là la modèle de chez nul biya
c'est le z 20 avec deux écrans en ce
moment parce que ça va être vraiment
intéressant le readme 5 on en parle
aussi dans quelques jours le élite 75 t
de chez jabra on en parle aussi très
bientôt
et puis celui là aussi smartphones de
gaming c'est le black shark deux pros on
en parle très très rapidement et si vous
voulez prendre la main sur la ligne
éditoriale choisir quels seront les
prochains tests trouver le bouton
s'abonner ces paliers niveau 2 et vous
choisissez
quels seront les prochains tests qu'on
va réaliser vole un peu pour idée
globale
concentrons-nous aujourd'hui sans ce
samsung galaxy à 81,81 qui en gros si
vous voulez le le 80 c'est le plus haut
de gamme dans la gamme à lagamas et le
milieu de gamme à savoir que la gamme a
réuni l'entrée de gamme et le milieu de
gamme
historiquement c'est le milieu de gamme
et ce à 80 c'est le plus haut de gamme
dont je dirais le milieu de gamme
smartphone qui est cool surtout un truc
qui est vraiment très intéressant
message le groupe juste à côté
[Musique]
non
ça c'est vraiment le truc que j'adore ce
que je fais à 80 c'est ça la tension est
prêt on n'y va pas un c'est petit
système de caméra qui monte et qui
descend avec un système rotatif les
regardaient vraiment prêt pour vous
rendez convoler samantha et ça tourne
quand vous lui mettez de l'autre côté de
regard des obstacles idée s'envoyer et
là c'est moi derrière j'appuie hop il
monte il tente donc le tout cas
intéressant il la grande force de ce
produit c'est qu'en fait la caméra
principale et caméra principale que vous
allez avoir à l'arrière deviennent vos
caméras de celle fille donc on n'a pas
une caméra de cette fille d'un mouton
moins bonne qualité il pouvait vraiment
l'exploiter pour la partie photo ça
c'est plutôt cool et on rentre on n'a
pas un truc de dingue moment parlé juste
après c'est un smartphone milieu de
gamme
attention il faut vraiment savoir le
repositionner par rapport à tout ça vous
allait dépendre sont vraiment cool
à commencer par l'écran il ya une belle
maîtrise depuis longtemps chez samsung
sur les écrans dans l'écran super amoled
full hd + 2000 400 pixels par 1080
pixels 6 7 pouces de diagonale 393
pixels par pouce on a un format vingt
neuvième un format un peu allongé mais
qui fonctionne mais surtout ce que
j'aime beaucoup les succès qu'on a pas
dans kof sur le côté on a pas de bulle
pas de trop en arrière en un seul même
et grand écran qui savent vraiment pour
le visionnage ça s'est vraiment bien on
a une petite bordure là qui est un peu
plus large sur le côté en bas qui dans
l'absolu ne dérange pas on est dans le
milieu de gamme mais on n'est pas sur
les dernières innovations
néanmoins je trouve qu'il ya un vrai
beau boulot qui fait là dessus et
lorsque vous aller taquiner le duo a dit
on va monter le son
on arrive ici face à lui matt hill voyez
on a un petit haut-parleur mono qui se
situe juste là son côté s'il paye
haut-parleurs stéréo bose inclus ce qu
on est sur glace la qualité audio est
pas forcément un petit peu légèrement à
saturer lorsque vous mettez de la voix
et lorsque l'on écouté de la musique est
sensiblement la même chose si c'est
vraiment à fond sa tendance un petit peu
à saturer satan légèrement souto faire
c'est venir baisser un peu son volume
est là tout de suite cette revue les
performances sont correctes sans être
dingue d'un snapdragon à 730 8 gigas de
ram 128 giga de stockage une batterie de
trois mille sept cent millions terreur
avec de la recharge rapide 25 watts et
batterie 3700 milliards eur vous
permettra de tenir une journée une
journée et demie si vous n'êtes pas trop
gourmand au tro bon non mais c'est pas
un truc complètement dingue c'est pas un
smartphone que jamais tenir deux jours
en autonomie
probablement la faute à cette date 2 6 7
pouces qui va être quand même
énergivores le processeur derrière le
737 un processeur milieu de gamme de
chez qualcomm qui fait le job qui fait
la faire vous n'êtes pas faire tourner
les jeux les plus gourmands vous allez
vite et des trucs qui me demandaient
plus de puissance mais pour faire
tourner beaucoup de jeu du leinster à
les 80% par un peu plus le jeu du castor
vous allez vraiment tranquille durant
absolument aucun problème ça marche bien
c'est un smartphone qui n'est pas le
plus autonome c'est un smartphone qui
n'est pas le plus puissant mais qui
franchement fait le taff et puis surtout
vous avez vous réconforte visionnage
hawk si vous aimez tout le côté
multimédia et bien vous êtes vraiment
tranquille on n'a pas non plus la
meilleure expérience audio parce que on
n'a pas à côté immersif à 10
haut-parleurs stéréo une fois de plus
son lait dans le milieu de gamme
voilà qu'on peut pas tout avoir le tarif
je vous dévoile à la fin mais bon ça me
paraît quand même aujourd'hui
relativement cohérent matin des
difficultés c'est par rapport à la
concurrence chinoise
il ya beaucoup de constructeurs pour les
smartphones qui sont très performants
très endurant dans le même tarif
et là ça peut être un petit peu
difficile pour samsung vous avez
notamment un petit capteur d'empreintes
digitales lagarde et hop on passe de
doissat débrouille assez rapidement un
smartphone qui est joli je vous dis pas
non encore une fois de plus ça j'aime
bien et lorsque vous allez à l'arrière
vous avez un dos en verre alors qu'on a
du verre à l'avant on a du verre à
l'arrière on a du verre de tous les
côtés il ya un côté très premium avec ce
côté là voyez ce petit tour je sais pas
exactement ce que c'est ça fait un petit
peu de thé bronze
ça chauffe ça prévient me sens vraiment
très jolie peu de galber sur le côté on
retrouve le branding samso d'ici là bon
par contre il prend quand même les
traces de doigts c'est un petit peu un
des points négatifs mais une fois de
plus sur un smartphone avec un dos en
verre c'est complètement normal vous
avez petit bouton pour l'allumer sur le
côté il a cp par contre en voyez c'est
un smartphone qui est quand même assez
mastoc je pense que ça vient de toutes
les technos vous avez à l'intérieur et
notamment pour avoir le petit slide ici
il est quand même épée il fait quand
même son point c'est un smartphone qui
fait 2 120 g on le sent dans la main ça
smartphones qui est grand qu'ils aient
payé voyez il faut bien le ceinture avec
sa main on y arrive mais par contre vous
aller naviguer à demain dessus c'est un
smartphone qui est grand ça va vraiment
il faut le savoir
ça c'est un peu ce que je pourrais venir
leur reprocher du point de vue de l'ol
on tourne sur - du high 1.1 basé sur un
android 9 alors - nuages c'est vraiment
bien terme d'expérience sim des
surcouches que je préfère ce qu elle
vraiment agréable vraiment cool les
icônes sont sympas vous aidez petit but
qui permet vraiment de vous y repérer
c'est très simple très intuitif très
pratique si vous connaissez pas one
yoann et si vous voyez ça nous sommes
dites vous bien que la surcouche elle
vraiment cool et ça apporte beaucoup de
confort à la navigation au niveau de la
partie photo j'ai retrouvé avec surtout
deux caméras même si vous en avez 3 le
caméra principale c'est la saône yannick
586 et une tanière
48 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0 on est
deuxième caméra 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à
f 2.2 sont ultra grand angle avec un
champ de vision de 123 degrés et puis à
troisième caméra servira pour le mode
portrait pour les faits évoqués alors je
vous dis d'intérêt c'est que comme vous
avez un petit sly comme si rotatif comme
ça tourne vous avez exactement la même
chose pour les photos vous allez prendre
à l'arrière mais également à l'avancé de
fille donc ça s'est vraiment bien
longuet sur la caméra principale eu 48
mégapixels je trouve que c'est pas mal
quand même un beau détail au niveau des
feuilles elles ressortent bien c'est
qu'il semble assez justement c'est quand
même pas mal de petits détails mais si
je viens souvent un peu la sas et ça
c'est vraiment une soixantaine très
qualitatif
une fois de plus sur un smartphone
milieu de gamme dont ça fonctionne dès
que j'ai pas sur lui très grand temps
que ces mois en sachant que c'est tout
de suite dé saturer gagner on va
remonter prendre la photo d'avant le
fond qui est vert plus foncé et vers un
peu plus clair ici un peu plus pâle
c'était une vraie différence est à mille
différences significatives entre le
capteur principal est le second capteur
s'est pas complètement ouf on continue
ensuite on sait la même photo que j'ai
reprise après pour bien venir voir
contrôler et je vois bien les détails la
voyez les petits poils au niveau de la
tige et petits poils au niveau de la
fuite donc je trouve ça vraiment bien
une photo prise bien évidemment en en
mode selphy mais avec la caméra
principale parce qu'on est sur un
appareil plutôt rotatif et bien ça fait
le taf c'est très bien ça marche c'est
complètement normal on continue sur des
petites feuilles automnale ça marche
mais dès que je suis vite ch sur la
caméra grand angle sont ultra
grand-angle de 123 degrés mais voyez on
perd tout de suite en saturation
c'est vraiment significatif je peux
changer entre les deux on va vraiment la
différence très très très très
impressionnant s'est quand même un peu
dommage on continue un petit buisson pas
ont des ceintures avec les caméras ultra
grand-angle une jolie petite feuille paf
ont des statuts redon gérer ses traits
d'un petit bout d'os en bas mais je vais
corriger sur la photo d'après je les
enlever on met facilement son doigt
devant faut vraiment faire très
attention la façon dont va venir lire
son smartphone tenir son smartphone
c'est mieux comme ça ensuite on continue
ici caméra principale up ultra
grand-angle ça des ceintures c'est
dommage c'est un peu plus jeunes là là
c'est beaucoup plus pâle bon voyez c
c'est pas extrêmement of mais ça fait le
taf
or là on est sur le mode portrait
l'heure loin de portraits j'ai eu un
petit peu de marge que je le tenais la
main voiliers et bien c'est un peu flou
je trouve au niveau de mon visage
on est bien le flou derrière mais le
le visage était pas terrible terrible
terrible j'ai continué à la main alors
par contre un peu la catastrophe
je les pose et ensuite avec un petit
retardateur et là ça marchait
parfaitement bien m'a bien des tours et
entre les doigts sales a bien repéré le
contour du visage aussi est très juste
ça marche quelques petits cheveux là
mais c'est pas complètement anormal ça
fonctionne plutôt bien ça des tours très
bien ici le pouce et bien des tours et
là d'un point de vue logiciel ça
fonctionne on sent même plutôt bien je
venu chercher ensuite sur des photos sur
un mode un peu plus nuit là j'ai eu un
petit peu de mal un franchement je vous
le cache pas je pense que c'est pas
vraiment fait pour y avait une lumière
pas j'ai coupé toutes les lumières gelé
tenu à la main lorsque j'ai regardé ces
cas pas de stabilisation optique et là
on voit très clairement c'est flou
l'appareil photo de lui à 80 fonctionne
donc lorsque vous avez beaucoup de
lumière dès qu'il ya un peu moins de
lumière ça fonctionne moins bien il a un
peu de mal il ya un peu poussif en
conditions de faible luminosité
c'est pas son truc hein il est fait pour
fonctionner dans les conditions
optimales
son capteur 48 mégapixels sur la caméra
principale ou d'une femme plus ça tu
seras grand-angle ça peut être rigolo
pour des effets mais c'est un peu
dommage en fait le truc qui est un peu
dommage haut niveau la photo c'est que
c'est vraiment un des gros focus qui
fait sur ce 80 sade avoir notamment
cette petite caméra rotative vous dites
j'ai la meilleure qualité que ce soit à
l'avant comme à l'arrière est en réalité
la qualité est pas mal mais pas dingue
et connaissant la qualité de saint cloud
qui sont capables de faire en termes de
photos et bien c'est dommage que sur un
module comme ça qu'il faut coup très
original il soit pas allée extrêmement
loin on est sur un smartphone qui
coûtent en effet le prix là coûte le
coup de la main et d'apple qui veulent
qu'elle 199 euros on peut trouver un peu
moins cher vous aimez d'ailleurs des
liens en bas dans la description s'il
vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à laisser
un petit coup d'oeil à cliquer dessus et
bien je trouve que ils sont pas là c'est
loin dans la démarche peut-être se
sont-ils dit ok on est sur ce point le
plus haut de gamme dans le milieu de
gamme ne peut pas tout mais qu'on peut
pas mettre les meilleurs et nous
condamnons le très haut de gamme sur la
gamme s est bien c est peut-être ce
qu'il aurait fallu faire dire ok on va
faire très gros focus quitte à voir
cette techno puisque pour moi le truc
très intéressant il faut qu'on ait ce
qui se passe de mieux en terme de photos
comme ça faisait profiter de la
meilleure qualité que ce soit à l'avant
comme à l'arrière typiquement si vous
prenez un samsung galaxy s 10 ou alors
un no 19 10 plus c'est bien ce qui
serait génial c'est d'avoir les mêmes
caméra à l'arrière comme à l'avant on
aurait là me
qualité on peut faire des sales fidh
dingue on pourrait faire un ultra grand
angle avec la meilleure qualité ça
serait génial mais là pour le coup c'est
dommage parce que je dirais pas que
c'est un peu un coup d'épée dans l'eau
mais ils vont pas assez loin
ils vont pas assez loin et c'est
vraiment un truc que je regrette parce
que cette techno bien vous ne retrouvez
pas sur la gamme s ni sur la gamme note
alors que là vous l'avez dans la gamme a
et a
il manque un point de détail pour que ce
soit vraiment top à côté de ça l'écran
est vraiment bien très bien maîtrisé
très belles dalles de la part de samsung
le fait d'avoir un seul haut parleur
mono c'est pas mal mais c'est pas assez
immersif une fois de plus dans les
gammes passé pas très très problématique
est un truc est très rigolo
si vous regardez bien et bien vous
n'avez pas de haut parleurs aussi
beaucoup de filles c'est par une
vibration de la dalle donc au début
c'est un peu bizarre on a un peu de mal
à trouver sa position a bien calés sur
l'oreille pour ça marche une fois qu'on
l'a bien positionné ça marche ça ne
semble pas aussi bon que ce qu'on
pouvait avoir avec un haut-parleur
ça fait le cas pourquoi pas bon une fois
de plus c'est parce que je vais le
préféré mais offrait ce qui est
intéressant avec ce galaxy à 85 cents
contre ces capable de proposer 500
hommes en termes d'innovation dans le
milieu de gamme dans le haut de gamme du
milieu de gamme de pouvoir effectivement
se positionner face à des acteurs
innovants comme notamment le petit slide
de repos avec le finepix ma ils le font
effectivement la samsung avec leur à 80
il manque encore des choses devraient
aller encore plus loin j'espère qu'on
2020 pourquoi pas reprendre le système
de slider mais aller un peu plus loin
essayé d'alléger un petit point en terme
de points c'est de rendre un peu plus
fin l'écran de 7 pouces pourquoi pas ça
fonctionne moi je trouve intéressant
j'aurais préféré plus endurants
également c'est un peu les points de
rédiger sur ce smartphone néanmoins
j'aime beaucoup et l'innovation qui a
été fait par samsung j'aime beaucoup ce
qu'ils ont tenté de faire avec ce
produit maison ok on a du milieu de
gamme le a50 et est le meilleur le plus
intéressant pour grand public au niveau
du milieu de gamme mais propose quelque
chose de vraiment top est vraiment
innovant avec 180 quitte à en vendre des
tonnes et à mon avis c'est un petit peu
le résultat c'est pas le smartphone qui
se vend le plus je pense que le a50 se
vend beaucoup plus mais par contre déjà
technologiquement il est quand même
vraiment intéressant je sais pas si vous
partagez mon avis est ce que vous le
trouver intéressant technologiquement
mais que vous craignez un petit peu pour
les vendre parce que ya évidement quand
même deux trois trucs et il est quand
même un petit peu cher notamment par
rapport à ce qu'on peut trouver à la
concurrence vous trouvez un dessin
dragon 855
à ce tarif là on voyait qu'il lui manque
pas grand chose à ce smartphone à côté
de ça vous avez quand même du nfc de
nous tous
5.0 c'est un produit que je trouve quand
même cool mais que par contre titre
personnel et
pas acheter ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire et quant à nous on se
retrouve je vous dis dès demain pour
parler de plein de choses je sais pas
parce qu'on va commencer un venez faire
votre choix directement en devenant
membre de la chaîne choisira les
produits qu'on va tester vous avez le
petit bouton s'abonner qui doit être
juste en dessous là où juste en dessous
là je ne sais jamais quelle caméra c'est
compliqué à savoir sur ce je vous
embrasse vous fait des gros belge en
voie de l'amour toute mon affection vous
souhaite de joyeuses de joyeuses fêtes
je ne sais pas s'ils vont recoller cette
vidéo fin décembre ou si vous la
regardez plus tard en 2020 moi je la
tourne là on est quelque chose comme le
15 décembre voyait ça c'est plutôt cool
je vous fais des gros bisous j'en veux
de l'amour et à très bientôt
ciao